we finished each other side decision
[Music]
I just flipped through to see what I had
to do you're lying you alive you're
alive I think I was in Los Angeles I was
working on something else and it came in
and I had I had other work I should have
been doing but I just dropped everything
I mean it's so exciting you know we're
only a few months ahead of the rest of
the world with this stuff because there
aren't there isn't a series of books so
very rare thing because normally if you
read a script for something you're
deciding whether to do it or whether to
audition for it and it's a different
thing when you're like oh I'm doing this
so so how and so you can't cut away the
sort of how am I going to do it as
you're going through well I remember
when you asked that question is I got
real real anxiety because I remember the
first day of filming the first film
which was a scene with Katherine in the
in which is mert lap bursts out and Dan
Bert's out of this out of this case and
I was so nervous and I was wearing all
these layers of tweed and it was summer
if I just sweated so much they basically
had to stop filming they had to bring in
an air conditioner I'm blasting only on
me everyone else does in coats no one
else is fine but I was so nervous that
they were just having to come a cake my
so I actually turned any brings me in
higher didn't think about it my first
thing that this one was with little
picket the first time you see Newt and
with Zoey seeing little a strange for
the first time and staring at her shoes
and it was also really weird because the
first time Lolita
and newts each other David Yates our
director had us do this thing where we
stare into the camera rather than two at
each other so I'm meant to be showing
this sort of whole history of a
relationship staring straight down the
barrel of a lens I found it really hard
we had about 900 takes
[Music]
sometimes be easier yeah yeah yeah
there's like nobody holding me back
bringing me down or just old soda like
your levels this is really hard for me
but you know when I'm alone I can just
deliver my
[Music]
they'd already started I think they're
done at least for four for five weeks
and I got it'll come in during that time
to have costume fittings and beard
length fittings and all and then the
whole of my opening scene which is with
Eddie
we shot over about a week didn't we so
your first thing was that first look in
all the trailers of Dumbledore
I think that's quite stressful your
first moment of the reveal of Dumbledore
having a turn around I would have been
scrutinizing when my nectar there was a
moment of really wonderful moment when
Newt and Tina and Lita are running away
from these things called matter goes
these spirit familiars they're kind of
cats in the French Ministry and newts
case falls out of his hand and Tina
basically jumps down to go and protect
it and then this cats are coming for new
and Lita beats the living hell out of
him out of them I actually saw a cart
that had that and it was pretty freakin
cool
and it got cut for time I'm hearing it
protecting
[Music]
riding the cal penis sort of underwater
Scottish creature that's like made of
seaweed you have to shoot underwater in
a tank and basically in order for the
takes to be quite long they wanted me to
learn to hold my breath really long so I
was sent to meet this free diver this
woman who can literally hold her breath
for about 25 minutes and she taught me
tonight Zen out and become really
chilled and and it was amazing over like
a day she sort of managed to extend my
breath bad news which I was so smug
about and I said to David dog we could
do 20-minute takes I guess and then of
course what I didn't realize is that
film set so that the most hard call
quite intense places and so the point is
in order to hold your breath that long
we have to be in an incredibly Zen place
and actually just before the tag cosmic
oh I can hold it for about 3 seconds
that's why it's a very short scene that
goalie
[Music]
I didn't know that it was available yeah
he wasn't offered I guess when you're
playing Dumbledore they're like you know
yeah I've carried a one length piece of
twig basically around with me for a
whole summer in preparation I just
wanted to get used to having this thing
and playing with it it depends how far
it goes over the next three but in a way
that would be amazing that Tom Riddle
yeah to see him say at Hogwarts being
taught by Dumbledore being told by work
yeah just even if it was just in passing
you the cinema someone else or they hold
up yeah it would be amazing
I think I'm given that I audition didn't
very very badly fails the part I don't
know I think it might be the one moment
if Tom Riddle to walk past a newt and
hope one
but then it'd be they're not gonna that
would be one of the reasons you see get
so messed up
[Music]